chef Shane Dryden is demonstrating an
induction cooker so how does it cook
food and stay cold at the same time
conventional cookers use a heat source
such as gas or an electric elements but
in an induction cooker the pan itself is
the heat source underneath the stovetop
is a circular copper coil and when
currents move through that coil it
creates magnetic fields when Shane puts
the pan on top of the cooker the
magnetic fields cuts through the steel
and creates a current in a process
called induction which is where the
cookers get their name how does the
magnetic field make the pan hug but not
the stovetop as these currents move
around in the pan what's happening is
that they're creating moving electrons
these moving electrons possess kinetic
energy and some of that kinetic energy
gets converted in the heat Shane is
using a stainless steel pan which is a
good choice because it's an electrical
conductor which will allow electrons to
flow around it heating it up whereas the
food that is just on the surface of the
cooker has little electrical conduction
and therefore no heat it is a great
invention and it'll definitely take off
when they fix the saucepans keep trying
guys
[Music]